[Müzik]
rahmetli Sait Faik bir sözü vardır Yazı
yazmayı çok önemli bir iş saydığımdan
başka bir iş yapmamaya karar vermişti
diye Ben de denizleri korumayı o kadar
önemli bir işim ki başka hiçbir iş
yapmadı bana
şimdi Bu gördüğünüz görüntü yok ama
körfezinden balık aşırı'dan
Türkiye'nin en büyük özel çevre koruma
bölgelerinden bir tanesi olmakla beraber
2008 yılında beni Türkiye'ye getiren
annesini kaybetmiş küçücük bir Akdeniz
fokunun rehabilitasyonu için başladığım
süreçte
okunan adı badem'dir
koruyucu anne babası rahmetli
gökova'ya saldığımızda hazır gelmişken
şurada bir suyun altında bakayım
dediğinde suyun altında bir nükleer
savaşıyor
ve inanın zannediyorsunuz ki dünyadaki
denizleri tehdidi kirliliktir plastiktir
değil bunlar çok basit sorunlar Bunlar
çok rahat çözebiliriz Bunlar mekanik
sloganlar Ama çözemeyeceğimiz bir sorun
varsa burada balık avcılığı
Akdeniz'de 10.000 yıldır Balıkçılık var
ve balıklarının %86'sı tamamen tüketmiş
durumda
Şimdi size
Roma'daki bir kaynaktan tarihe bir
kaynaktan elde ettiğimiz inanılmaz bir
hikaye anlatayım
İmparator tiberyus dönemi yıl 42
Akdeniz'de Bir barbun türü var iki buçuk
3 kiloya varıyor çok sırada yaşıyor ve o
kadar lezzetli ki o kadar çok avlanıyor
ki hayvanın nesli tükenmek üzere
İmparator tiberyus bileklerasyon
yayınlıyor
bugünden sonra diyor bu balık sadece
İmparator Ailesi mensupları tarafından
yenilebilecektir
ertesi gün Roma'nın Kara borsasında bir
barbun bir ineği değişecek
ve o balık türü bundan 2000 yıl önce
insanın aşırı avlamasından dolayı yok
bakıyor
yıl önce insanoğlu olarak akdenizli
sayının tüketim şeysi
bu ki tarihi kaynaklarda bu var
olmayanlar
hiç bilmediklerimiz daha neleri tükettik
biliyor muyuz
bu kadar insan koruma ile ilgileniyor
Dünyada bu kadar koruma ile ilgili
sözler söyleniyor directive çevre
programı var Hiç merak ettiniz mi
dünyadaki kararların ne kadar korunuyor
dünyadaki karaların %14'ü korunuyor
dünyadaki denizlerin ne kadarı korunuyor
biliyor musunuz
kağıt üzerinde yüzde yedi
gerçek anlamda %1'den az bakın burada
bir rakam var
30x30 kampanyası diye İngiltere Çevre
Bakanlığı
2030'a kadar
ülkeler
karalarının ve denizlerinin yüzde
otuzunu koruma altına alacak bu
%30'ların içerisindeki %10'da her şeye
karşı kapatılacak bu denizlerde
balıkçılığa ve bütün diğer etkilere
karşı demek olan gene şimdiki rakamlara
bakalım akdenizin tamamı gibi işte altın
Türkiye'deki denizlerin yüzde üçünü
koruyoruz gerçek anlamda balıkçılar
Kapalı alan dediğiniz
Akdeniz'de Avrupa Birliği Merkezi olan
Akdeniz ile bizde sıfırla sıfır
Yani biz hedeflerin daha binde birliğini
bile karşılayabiliriz
Bakın bu yüzde bir sarı nokta bütün
dünyayı kaplayan okyanuslarda gerçek
anlamıyla kurucusuyla mutuyla
yönetimiyle kurduğumuz
şey Hedef 2030'a kadar %30
var mı yakalama imkanı Bence yok
şimdi gelin başka bir tarafa bakalım
balıkçılar dünyada her yıl 35 milyar
dolar teşvik veriliyor
Amerika Birleşik Devletleri
bu para birilerine daha yüksek
teknolojiyle daha büyük teknelerle daha
az balığı avlayabilmesi için veriliyor
Türkiye'de de belirli
yediğiniz bana hiçbirinin fiyatı bugünkü
fiyat değil
ne zaman bu teşvikler biter o zaman
adının gerçek bir çıkar Bakın şimdi
başka bir rakama geçelim
ben ne şimdi trafikte çalışırken bir
hesaplama yaptık bundan 8 sene önce
okyanusların %20'sini korumak için ne
gerekiyor ne kadar paraya ihtiyacımız
var diye yılda 16 milyar dolara
dünyadaki okyanusların
Ve bunu yaparken de 1 milyon kişi iş
olan
ağı 35 milyar teşvik verilirken
kimse bize 16
kuruş ve belki takip etmişsinizdir bir
buçuk ay önce Avrupa Birliği'nde
ekosistem restorasyon yasası Hazırlandı
ve yürürlüğe girdi Benim de bununla
ilgili Avrupa'daki en büyük denizlere
sistem projesini yürüttüğümüz için
konuşmacı olarak çağırdılar bu teşvikler
Şimdi gelelim Türkiye'ye
ülkemizde
güneybatı kıyılarımızda 5 tane çok
önemli özel çevre koruma bölgesi var
bunların bir tanesi yok o var
çalıştığımız şu anda diğerlerinde de
çalışıyoruz
Cambridge Üniversitesi'nin bünyesindeki
tehdit altındaki coğrafyalar Programı
avrupa’nın 8 Büyük ölçekli ekosistem
Restorasyonu projesinden biri olarak
bize teklif getirdi ve tek deniz projesi
Gökova'da başlatmış olduğumuz projeyi bu
görmüş olduğunuz Diğer alanlarda da
yapıyoruz
şimdi neler yapıyoruz
Bakın ben ne dedim 2008'de geldim suyun
altına girdim ve bir nükleer savaş
gördüm hiçbir şey
bunun üzerine
çok büyük bir proje yaptık Çünkü milyon
dolarlık bir projeye başladık Kuzey
Akdeniz kıyılarında korunan ve
korunmayan alanlarda dalaraktan ne
durumda Sadık nedir ona baktık
te metrekareye dönen balık size o
reset'in ne kadar sağlıklı olduğunu
4 gram metrekare ile 2008 yılında
Akdeniz'de en az balık yaşayan
ekosistemi tamamen çökmüş olan yer Şimdi
siyah noktalı yerlere bakın siyah
Yıldızlar iyi korunan balıkçılığa kapalı
alanları gösteriyor bakın İspanya'daki
lavabolara medes bunlarda 100 gram
metrekare balık var
kırmızı yıldızlarsa Kağıt üzerindeki
koruma alanları statüsü Var mı resmi
olarak var ama sahada kimse var mı hiç
kimse yok corondan alanlarla yani
kırmızılarla hiç korunmayan adamlar
arasında bir fark yok demek ki bunların
hepsi kağıttan Korumalar denizde
olmadığını sürece hiçbir şey ifade
etmiyor
gökova'nın özelliği de var
kritik türler var mikrofonda Akdeniz
popomuz var kütüphanede nasıl kalan
Konak Denizde
Bu köpek balıkları var son derece
hırpalanmış avlanmış sayıları çok
azalmıştı orfoz gibi tehdit altında
türler var ve
bu iki Deniz koruma alanı yok babayla
Datça Bozburun Birbirine çok yakın ve
biz 2008 2009 yılında balıkçılara
gittiğimizde
ve daha da önemlisi öğrenilen teke
boyuna kadar güldür ve trolle kapalı
Yaklaşık 300 kilometrekarelik bir alan
ilan ettirdik devletimize ki bu hala
Avrupa Birliği sınırları içerisinde
girilir ve kapalı en büyük
şimdi bu alanları kim koruyacak sahil
güvenlik Ören'de var ama orada mülteci
krizi en üst seviyedeydi tüm Zavallı
sahil güvenlikler
kurtarmakla uğraşıyorlar biz dedik ki
kendi koruculuk gücümüzü koruralım
Bu arada bir şey daha göstermek
istiyorum bakın geçmişte boyda
okyanuslar bugün bu Eğer iyi korursak
İngilizcesi
balıkçılar kapatırsak iyi korursak bu
olabilir Daha az korursak da aslında
hiçbir faydası olmuyor bu bizim geçen
sene science dergisinde yayınladığımız
bir makalenin çizimi
şimdi bakana kadar çıktık Dedik ki sahil
güvenlik bu işi yapamıyor Biz bu işi
Akdeniz Koruma Derneği olarak yapacağız
bana ne biliyor musunuz devlet bolluk
gücü yetkisini 3 şahıslara devredemez
Zafer Devlet
Biz dedik yetki istemiyoruz
Ben bir Türkiye Cumhuriyeti vatandaşı
olarak anayasanın bana verdiği bir suç
durumunda her Türk vatandaşı kolluk
kuvvete gelene kadar suçluyu tutma zapt
etme ve kaydı altına alma hakkına sahip
Bu benim anayasal Yetkin
Ben kimseye ceza kesmek istemiyorum Ben
orada siz gelene kadar kovulduk kuvveti
gelene kadar bu işi yapmak için gönüllü
olmak istiyorum dedim
öyle başladık ilk başta eski balıkçıları
aldık katmamıza
botlar verdik altlarında Amerika'daki
yazılım yaptırdık özel bir telefonları
var Ben bilgisayara Başladığım zaman
hangi koruyucu botumu nerede Ne yapıyor
bakışta ne gelmiş ne tür bir yasadışı
aktiviteye Tanık olmuş Bunların hepsini
fotoğrafları ve videolarıyla anlık
olarak geliyor ve biz de bunları anlık
olarak genç sahil güvenlikle hem de
tarım bakanlığıyla paylaşıyoruz
korucularımıza Ateş edildi
koruyucularımız dayak yedi ama yılmadık
sürekli alanları korumaya devam ettik
yılda Sadece 150 bin dolarlık yakıt
yapıyoruz İki tane de ee kadın
koridorunuz var şu anda ben bu konuşmayı
yaparken Siz otururken onlar yasa dışı
balık avlanmasın diye bir balığın daha
hayatını kurtarmak için devreye deler
Dolayısıyla on kişilik bir konuşup
gücümüz var
ve bakın yazın bir kulet Instagram
sayfasında 5 tane olumsuz zıpkınla
vurduğunu Instagram'da paylaşmış
kesinlikle korunan bir tür kurulması
gerekmesi her türlü Ticaret yasak
teknenin yerini tespit ettik sahil
güvenlikle
bulunan insanlara karşı kötü
Ben bir balığın dahi hayatına
önemsiyorum orada Çünkü o bir balık
onlara ait değil O bir balık mı
sabahında oturan herkesin çocuklarının
akrabalardan Onlar bizim balıklarımız
kimseye verilmiş bir hak yok böyle
ve 2010 yılından beri onlarca ağır
çıkardık suyun altından atılmış kalp ve
boş
ve bakın 2012 yılında
alanlar yeni ilan edildiğinde Burası
koruma alanı Balıkçıların hiçbir şey var
mı Sizce
misinalardan başka kopmuş hiçbir şey yok
bu misinaları tek tek çok diyorsunuz
ağları çıkarmak çok kolay
ve sadece bir adanın etrafından yanlış
duymuyorsunuz 5000 kilometre işine
temizledik 500 değil 5000 Kilometre şu
anda kafama körfezinde benim tahminime
göre milyonlarca kilometre
biz sadece balıkçılar kapalı alanları
temiz
ve 7 yıl sonra aynı nokta bakın
misinalar olmayınca o tartılmayınca
süngerler miydi süngerler büyünce
onların Etrafında bir sürü canlı oldu
avcılık olmayınca balıklar geri geldi Bu
sadece 7 yıl
da 7 yılda tekrar Deniz
Tamam belki mükemmel seviyesine ulaşmadı
Akdeniz'de Mükemmel seviyenin ne
olduğunu da bilmiyoruz ama Deniz gibi
geldi Deniz iyileşmeye başladı
büyük balık olması lazım insandan önce
denizde Sadece büyük balıklar hakim
di sayamıyoruz onlar bile biliyorlar
nerede yaşamaları gerektiğini dışarıda
avlanıyorlar Dolayısıyla sadece Kapalı
alanda balıkçılar kapalı alanlar bu
balıkların soğuk kaleleri ve Kum köpek
balıkları 2010'da çok az sayıları
bunların yaşadığı alana yüzmeye dahi
kapattırdık şu anda suyun altında
çok kompleks kameralarımız var Çevre ve
Şehircilik bakanınızla beraber bir
izleme programımız var kanalında
kameramız var suyun altında
kameralarımız var
sürekli çekim yapıyorlar Bir de bir
akıllı
tasarım yaptırdık yazılım yaptırdık
silikon vadisinde firmaya kamera köpek
balıklarını tanıyorlar bireysel olarak
betonarolar cins olarak bile tanıyorlar
her köpek balığı geçişte bizi hemen
sinyal geliyor ve
köpek balığı şikayetleri daha önce de
geçmişi diyor Ve böylece alanda köpek
balığı sayısını dışı erkek dağılımında
hangi mevsimlik geldiklerini benim için
en zevkli kısımsa sabahleyin açtığımda
köpek balıklarımı kameradan görebiliyor
olmak
2010 yılında Körfez'de bir tane Akdeniz
topuğundan bahsediyordu balıkçılar
körfezdeki bütün mağaralara baktık 4
tane üreyebilecekleri mağara bakıp bu
mağaraların üzerine yine gerçek zamanlı
4K kamera sistemleri yerleştirdik hiçbir
şekilde zarar rahatsız etmeyelim diye
Bunlar infred kameralar 4K kalitesinde
Bakın bu gece yarısı bir çekilmiş
herhalde Sabah 2.54'te 2 tane dişi
mağarayı kullanırken ve kameradaki
yazılım yine sırtlarımdaki çizgilerden
bütün popları tek tek ayırt ediyor
hepsinin bizde bir ismi var Daha önce bu
genelde miydi ne zaman çıktı en son yeni
bir yağmur olduğunu ne kadar şu an şu
anda 11 top
hepsini izleyebileceğiniz bir görüntümüz
var
2017 yılında bir mağara keşfettik
İçerisi Muazzam güzeldi ama konuların
çıkabileceği grubu platform yoktu Buraya
bir platform inşa etmeye karar verdik
bakanlıktan izni aldık tek tek Kayalar
getirdik sonra üzerine kum çuvalları ile
çimento çuvallarıyla kapladık sonra
çakıl koyduk ve kamera
ve 4 ay sonra bir erkek bir ilişki soğuk
o mağarayı kabul ederler bu Marmara
yaşamaya başladılar Bu ilk kez dünya
tarihinde insan eliyle ne istedik
derecede tehdit altında bir ürün yaşama
ve hakikat alanını arttırmak için
başarılı olmuş bir aktivitedir daha
başka mağaralar da var içerisinde
tadilat yaptırmak istediğimiz şu anda
onları çatışıyoruz
Bakın bu görmüş olduğunuz bizim iklim
değişikliği isteme programımız Mert
arkadaşımız bahsetti bir buçuk dereceden
Dönüş Yok o dünya ortalaması için
Maalesef o Akdeniz için bu 4 katı Bizim
bütün modellemelerde 6 derece çıkıyor
Doğu Akdeniz
biliyor musunuz
pembe olan derinlerde ne oluyor her 5
metrede bir sıcaklık ölçerlerimiz var
Bunları programlıyoruz senkronize olarak
her saat başı sıcaklığı ölçüyorlar ve
bunları her yıl çıkarım grafik alıyoruz
Bakın bu grafikte çok önemli bir şey var
en üstteki 2015 yılı şu çizgiye bakın 20
metre çizgisinde sıcaklık değişim var
biz buna termokil
20 metrede sıcaklık değişir soğur
aşağıda bir sürü Sünger Mercan Bu
habitatlar soğuk suda yaşamayı sever
Bakın 2016'da bu çizgi 30 metreyi inmiş
2017'de Bu çizgi neredeyse 40'a iniyor
2018'de
2022 verileri için haftaya gidip
çıkaracağım cihazları Alın size iklim
değişikliği her sene 5 Metre 5 Metre 5
Metre sıcak suda aşağıya gidiyor Buna
neye sebep oluyor
bunun ne olduğunu bilen var mı dünyanın
en büyük midesi bir 50 santime kadar
büyüyor
Günde 4 ton su süzebiliyor
ve daha da önemlisi bakın üzerinde
süngerler büyüyor bir yaşam alanı
oluştur
uyor 2018 yılında
eşimle beraber bir deniz seyahatimdeyken
kendisi Deniz bir yarı olur her zaman
yanında örnek şişeden taşın tüm planlara
da dururken gördüm örnekleri ne ağlayın
ve 2018 yılında
Akdeniz'deki bütün inanan bir liste
hiçbirinizin haberi yokken hiç birimizin
haberi yokken suların altında bizim
çağımızda bizim devrimizde
milyarlarca yurtları orada olan bir cami
yok nesli tükendi
Haberimiz var umursuyor muyuz ama kim
bilir kaç tane deniz canlısı bununla
beraber kalbi
ve bakın
kendi mezar taşını daha ölmeden diken
tek canlıdır inanamayız hepsi öldü
Sağdaki eşim İnci
Geçen hafta Bakanlığın iklim değişikliği
projesinin danışmanıdır aynı zamanda
dalışlara gitti
Bana bir telefon edişi var böyle
ağlamaklı korktum bir şey oldu zannettim
canlı canlı buldum 15 santim dedi ya
ağlıyor konuşurken
bir tane canlı piano 1000 istiyormuş işi
ve canlı Çin Gökova
çok büyük Umut Belki geri gelecek ben
kaybolmadım Dolayısıyla suların altına
korunması lazım bunların üzerine Demir
atılıyor bunların üzerinde troller
çekiyor ve su sıcaklığı artınca bakın
İstilacı türler geliyor bu istidatı
türler balıkçının yakaladığı balığın
%85'i şu anda hiçbir para yetmiyor
balıkçıdan aldık Türkiye'deki üst düzey
Restaurant şefleri bunlardan menüler
hazırladılar ve İstanbul'da ilk kez
Türkiye'de ilk kez Sevgili Mehmet gülsün
miktarı aslan balığı menüsünü aldı her
hafta kendilerine gönderiyoruz ve daha
yılbaşından bu yana 5700 kilo küçük
balıkçıdan aslan balığı satın almışız
dernek olarak ve bunların restoranlara
vermişiz alternatif bir gelir yaratmış
ız dediğiniz çayırların
Deniz çayırları belki birçoğunuzun
haberi yoktur dünyada en fazla karbon
depolayabilen bitki
metrekarede 8 kilogramla dünyanın en
fazla karbon depolayan bitkisi
Dolayısıyla bu bitkinin korunması çok
önemli her yerde örnekler alıyor yalnız
aşağıda ne kadar karbon biriktiği ile
ilgili ve dolayısıyla Şu anda onların
korunması için çok büyük bir planımız
var bakın balıklarımızın boyları artık
kadın balıkçıları nasıl çok daha büyük
balıklar yakalıyorlar artık
gökova'dan bir küçük balıkçının tadı
balıkçının oğluyla yapmış olduğu bir
Avdan sahne ve 2013 yılından beri
balıkçının aylık gelirindeki artış hala
çok ciddi olarak yukarı gidiyoruz ve
beyaz Kaos geri döndü %45'ine tekrar
kooperatifin gelirlerine hakim 2017
dünyanın en iyi koruma projesi seçildi
bunun üzerine
tehdit altındaki
sistem Restorasyonu projesinden birini
götürüyoruz
bakanlıklarda çok yoğun bir şekilde
çalışıyoruz onları ikna etmeye
çalışıyoruz İnşallah Türkiye'nin 30
şartımız kampanyasını yakın bir dönemde
imza atacağımızı biliyoruz
[Alkış]